and we're back today we're talking about
the new cloud operations sandbox
data security strategies and a new app
sheet tutorial
i'm jenny brown and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news cloud operation
sandbox is an open source tool that
helps you learn
sre practices from google and then apply
them on cloud services using google
cloud's operations suite
it's got everything you need to get
started in just one click
so be sure to check out the blog post
for more information
our new white paper explores the
questions of building a data security
program
in a cloud-native way and of adapting an
existing program to utilize cloud
computing services
read the blog post for more best
practices and background information
or download the paper to learn for
yourself app sheet is google cloud's no
code app development platform
and this tutorial walks you through it
by building a usable fitness
app and more importantly it provides you
the skills to build any app you'd like
without needing to code a new year is a
great chance to learn something new
and i recently had the opportunity to
learn directly from kazzy kozakov
our head of decision intelligence check
out the podcast to hear more about the
role of decision makers
your intuition and data in decision
making
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
it in the cloud